donc qu'est ce que vous dites là ça doit
être vrai parce que vous le jurer sur la
tête de mât d'arc de fond qui va passer
un petit coup de fil dit à l'heure et
bouderait qu'on lui passe un coucou
coucou à la koko geneviève beaucoup tata
yoyo
est-ce que sur la tête de madame de
fontenay
vous n'avez jamais posé nue enlève le
bâton qui le fera en plein sera-t-elle à
madame buffoni je passerai jamais jamais
est-ce que sur la tête de madame de
fontenay vous n'avez jamais volé dans un
magasin
attention ce que vous dites là c'est
important si vous montez elmer à
l'instant où ces agressions conjurons
nature la tête de quelqu'un la personne
peut mourir là mais est-ce que sur la
tête de madame de fontenay on vous a
jamais dit que j'étais un mauvais coup
est-ce que sur la tête de madame de
fontenay vous n'allez jamais piqué le
mec d'une amie ça c'est important est ce
que sur la tête de madame de proclif je
n'avais jamais acheté de drogue une
bonne moralité ça m'étonne pas qu'ils
aient choisi
est-ce que sur la tête de la même
fontaine et vous n'avez jamais couché
pour devenir miss france jamais jean
pierre foucault
aussi bon et je suis sur la tête des
volumes de vente et vous n'avez jamais
eu une relation homosexuelle
attention à l'école quand vous étiez
petit avec madame de fontenay la droite
c'est papa n'a rien à voir a sur la tête
de madame de fontenay vous avez toujours
été fidèle à nico vous n'avez jamais
trompé nico la longue vie à madame de
fontenay est ce que sur la tête de
madame de fontenay vos seins sont vraies
il espère y est nous sommes livrés à des
forces en faveur des petits gens qui
sont un des petits simple savez ça
dépend est ce que cela donne de fortes
et vous adorez inaugurait des
supermarchés
vous écoutez ça je sais pas pourquoi
tout le monde en parle en rigolant mais
la france sait pas que la jet set la
france c'est aussi le terreur et la
plupart des gens qui votent ce sont les
gens qui vont à intermarché donc je suis
fier aux comptes et depuis toute façon
je viens du sud je vais jamais vécu la
vie parisienne ça c'est que un mois que
j'y suis donc commentaires ça me fait
plaisir c'est beau un magasin de 8 le
soir entre biscuits à pithiviers et
meaux blaison